Gon
What makes Gon such a controversial protagonist?
On the surface Hunter x Hunter, Yoshihiro
Togashi’s long-running magnum opus is a
standard Shounen story. Each story arc focuses
on a well worn Shounen trope such as a training
sequence or a tournament arc, things that
Togashi has covered before inhis series
YuYuHakusho. But whereHunter x Hunterfundamentally
differs from the status quo is in the way
that it takes these formulas and breaks them
apart in interesting ways before returning
to its Shounen roots. In a 2018 interview
with Weekly Shounen Jump Magazine Togashi
revealed that with Gon he originally planned
to create a sort of good-boy type of character
that would, and I quote, win every ‘character
I would want for a son’ competition. But
as soon as he started writing his story, he
immediately realised that this sort of character
would not fit the story he had envisioned
at all. After all, what good boy would lightheartedly
and without so much as a second thought abandon
his foster mother to become a hunter and search
for the father who left him behind as a child
just to follow his own selfish path? And so
it was at that point back in 1998 when the
series published its very first chapter, that
he decided to try something a little bit different.
He came to the conclusion that the traditional
tropes of Shounen Manga would not work for
the world he was about to create, and so he
decided to twist the general perspective on
the genre in a number of unimposing, but nonetheless
highly impactful ways. As a result, Gon is
not your classic all-good-all-powerful Shounen
hero, but rather a realistic version of it,
that has to face real consequences for his
actions within the story world Togashi has
thrown him in. Thus, he has become one of
the most controversially discussed Shounen
protagonists in history, and in this video
I want to explore with you why I believe that
it makes Gon one of the most well-written
Shounen heroes of all time. //The theme of
Hunter x Hunter
Before we can dissect, how Togashi has designed
Gon as a character and what makes his take
on the trope of the Shounen protagonist so
unique, we first have to understand the general
theme of Hunter x Hunter as a series overall.
You might have heard before that the main
theme of Hunter x Hunter is morality and exploring
the thin lines between good and evil, black
and white. It’s undeniably true that morality
is a central part of the story’s premise.
However, I believe that the actual theme of
the story goes even further than this. Because
the theme, otherwise also known as the moral
argument of a story, contrary to common believe,
doesn’t refer to a general subject matter
such as love, class, power or good versus
evil. It much rather is the author’s view
on how to act in the world and therefore encompasses
a certain moral vision, that the author wants
to explore through his story. Therefore, by
definition I believe that morality as a concept
cannot be the overall theme of Hunter x Hunter
but much rather is a part of it. The actual
moral argument that Togashi is exploring in
the story, and that he also uses to explore
Shounen as a genre overall is - ‘What does
it mean to be human in a super-human world?’.
And this overall theme then includes other
important questions, such as ‘what does
it mean to hold power?’ and ultimately also,
‘what does it mean to be moral?’. If you
look closely enough, each character in the
story is a variation of that theme and that’s
exactly what I want to explore with you in
this series of videos, and I hope you enjoy
watching them, as much as I enjoyed making
them. //Gon & the split hero
So, why start with Gon? Well, Gon is of course
the protagonist of the story. However, Hunter
x Hunter takes a slightly different conceptual
approach to their character web than other
typical Shounen do. No matter if it’s Naruto,
Bleach or One Piece, amidst a usually very
well-crafted group of supporting main characters,
the hero always stands out clearly as the
central focus point of the story. Therefore,
Naruto is about Naruto himself becoming Hokage.
Bleach is about Ichigo following his destiny
as a Shinigami and exploring the supernatural
world. And One Piece is of course about Luffy
striving to find the One Piece and becoming
king of the pirates. But what about Hunter
x Hunter? While Gon does have a central desire
within his ambition to find his father Ging,
that is driving the story forward, it is neither
particularly intense nor is it very urgent.
The story has no overarching big evil to defeat,
no important object to be acquired and no
final destination to be reached. Rather than
following a straight line towards a major
goal, Gon and his friends follow a meandering
path without apparent direction. They cover
a great deal of territory in a haphazard way
and encounter a variety of characters from
different levels of society. At the same time
and in close relation to this, in Hunter x
Hunter the lines between protagonist and ally
become very very thin. So thin even, that
it’s fair to say that the story has not
one, but two protagonists - Gon and Killua,
with Gon being only a tad more important.
This trope of the buddy story, is quite common
in Hollywood movies, from stories like the
lord of the rings over 21 Jump street all
the way to pretty much any love story out
there being a typical example. But it is very
very rare in Shounen Anime and Manga. In a
buddy story, in essence, the hero is split
into 2 parts, with one being a bit more relevant
than the other and both main characters having
two different backgrounds, 2 different approaches
to life and 2 different sets of values and
talents. As a result, the whole becomes greater
than the sum of its parts and is what makes
the combination Gon and Killua such a strong
leading duo. These two protagonists are allies
throughout the course of the series, but at
the same time also have an overarching conflict
of values and actions, that gives character
development to both of them. So, as you can
see Gon is already fundamentally different
from other typical Shounen protagonists, simply
based on his role in the story. His desire
to find his father is not particularly intense
and he shares the role of the hero with his
buddy Killua, who has his very own set of
desires and weaknesses, and we will get further
into their relationship in the next video.
Now this insight, of the split hero, can be
boiled down even further to one of Hunter
x Hunter’s major strengths as a story: While
many writers believe that all you need is
a well-written hero that is the only person
that matters, Hunter x Hunter doesn’t live
from any individual character, but rather
from an intricately crafted WEB of characters
that interact with each other. As a result,
the main group of protagonists move the plot
along, but the don’t carry it all by themselves.
And thus, every single character that Togashi
introduces helps to define those around them.
So now that we have looked at the general
premise for Gon’s role in the story and
how it differs from conventional Shounen heroes,
let’s finally talk about his character arc.
//Gon Freecss: A dark coming-of-age story
At the beginning of the story, Gon is the
stereotypical shounen poster boy — young,
plucky, irrepressible, spiky hair — in the
first 20 or so episodes, he’s basically
Son Goku without the tail. He is seemingly
nothing but good natured, and depending on
your preferences as viewer his simple and
pure attitude was probably either incredibly
charming or almost intolerable. His main desire
is to find his father Ging and prove himself
in the world of hunters, both of which he
strongly idealises. Equipped with immense
talent, power and skill, he leaves the isolated
island he was raised on to take the hunter
exam and follow his dreams. Togashi makes
us believe that Gon, just as so many other
popular Shounen characters, will grow to become
a warrior of justice, fighting for what is
right. He gives us the impression that in
this story it will be easy to distinguish
who are the good guys and who are the baddies
wearing capes, just as we have been trained
to expect from so many other stories from
that generation. However, it quickly becomes
clear that the world of Hunter x Hunter is
quite cruel and unforgiving. Actions and mistakes
have real consequences here and Togashi basically
used Gon as a sort of literary guinea pig
to see what would happen to your typical Shounen
Hero, if you were to throw them into a realistic
world. And so slowly but steadily, as we pass
from arc to arc and get to see more and more
of the world and Gon’s interactions with
it, it becomes clearer and clearer that what
now separates Gon from most other Shounen
protagonists is his increasingly skewed moral
compass.
The fundamental lie that Gon believes about
the world is that everything is either black
or white and that there is a clear line between
good and evil. But since that is not how the
real world works, where morality is mostly
found on a spectrum of grey, Gon increasingly
struggles to define what is good and what
is bad, based on the childish naivety an 11
year old simply has. Since objectively judging
people’s complex actions and behaviour makes
it difficult to put them into one category
or the other, Gon bases his morality on himself
and his relationship with a person. People
he is familiar with, such as Killua, Leorio
or Kurapika are obviously good and are worthy
of his protection, while unfamiliar people
dying during the hunter exam are generally
ignored and not considered as important. Meanwhile,
people Gon is unfamiliar with, but that conduct
acts of violence and cruelty must obviously
be bad. This can strongly be seen when Gon
gets captured by the phantom troupe as he
despises them for taking innocent lives unrelated
to them. At the same time Gon also categories
people based on whether or not they are useful
to him or his friends. Next to his naivety,
this selfishness is Gon’s second major weakness
as a character. As a result his morality appears
to become increasingly skewed, where an objectively
evil and twisted character like Binolt, who
has massacred and eaten countless people,
is actually thanked by Gon simply for helping
him getfing stronger. To better understand
this development in Gon and how his story
ultimately reached the dark climax it did,
I think the best thing is to look at the central
relationship between hero and opponent. //Gon
& Hisoka
I think it is fair to say that Gon’s relationship
with Hisoka is to Hunter x Hunter what unnecessarily
dramatic music is to this channel. Without
it, it just wouldn’t feel the same. So,
when we first get introduced to Hisoka, Togashi
promises us the typical Shounen good-guy-takes-on-bad-guy
relationship between him and Gon. Hisoka is
a psychopathic Clown and the apex of hedonism,
who cuts off another contesters arms simply
for bumping into him right at the start of
the hunter exam. He will stop at nothing to
get what he wants, no matter the damage it
does to himself or others. As a result, at
the beginning of their relationship Gon and
Hisoka appear to be clear-cut opposites, right
down to Hisoka’s appearance as a scary,
blood-thirsty clown — which as we know is
the mortal enemy of kids everywhere. Nonetheless,
despite all their seeming differences, over
the course of the story, both characters find
themselves inextricably drawn to each other.
What started off as our typical good-hero
vs evil-opponent dynamic, slowly blurs into
an uncomfortable similarity between the two.
Their shared desire to better themselves through
combat and their ecstatic enjoyment of battle
is nothing unique toHunter x hunter, however
most Shounen tend to shy away from so blatantly
highlighting this objectively problematic
stance of their main characters. Togashi on
the other hand, makes it easy to imagine a
small misstep in Gon’s life pushing him
into a position similar to Hisoka’s. And
we can see this in the story in a number of
ways. The best example however might be Hisoka’s
fight in the Heaven’s Arena arc against
the over-confident Kastro. Simply to prove
his superiority and provide a show, Hisoka
sacrifices both his arms to gain the upper
hand (no pun intended), and to satisfy his
desire to dominate and humiliate his opponent.
Then, a little later during the Greed Island
arc, Gon mirrors this morbid sacrifice against
the bomber Genthru. He abandons a carefully
thought out plan by taking an explosive attack
from Genthru which results in him losing an
arm, basically for no other reason but his
desire to prove his superiority and humiliate
his opponent. In a weird way, Gon and Hisoka
become more and more similar throughout the
story to the point where Hisoka almost functions
as a sort of mentor for Gon, a dynamic that
we will explore in more detail in another
video. Now however, we can finally look at
what Gon’s character arc looks like over
all. //Gon’s Character Arc
To summarise what we have discussed so far,
Gon’s character arc shows us what happens
to a naive 11 year old boy that holds enormous
physical power, when he is increasingly confronted
with the harsh & cruel reality of the real
world. This is basically the coming-of-age
story line we know from other Shounen, such
as Naruto, only that Gon doesn’t have a
positive arc, but a negative one. Instead
of growing more emotionally and morally mature,
his character is slowly crushed by the brutal
reality of the Hunter x hunter world. This
twist on the always-rising shounen protagonist,
had not been explored in this much detail
before and has lead to the very mature vibe
hunter x hunter carries as a series. The premise
for Gon’s development throughout the story,
as we have already discussed, are his naivety
and his selfishness. Both of these things
don’t necessarily make him a bad person,
but simply an inexperienced and overwhelmed
child. Nonetheless, based on these weaknesses,
Gon’s character is set up to learn about
the complex moral fabric of society and form
more a realistic view of the world. This need
is also moral, since through his basic moral
compass and his naivety, combined with his
enormous power he starts to hurt people around
him. However, it is not until the chimera
ant arc, that Gon completely spirals into
a complete loss of his morality and ultimately
his humanity. There are two events in particular
towards the beginning of the arc, that are
representative for this change. The first
is Gon’s first ever kill in the story. A
low-ranked Armadillo chimaera ant that bluntly
attacks him and that Gon then slowly crushes
to death. While it is understandable that
Gon defends himself and maybe even has to
kill the chimera ant, the complete lack of
reaction and emotional response to this act
is what is truly shocking here. The pure Gon
we got to know at the beginning of the story
would never had been able to do such a thing,
at least without being deeply affected by
it. Yet, Gon has already been so consumed
by power and violence that not only is he
unshaken by his first kill, but doesn’t
even give it a second thought. And even more
impactful, is the death of his mentor Kite,
who is killed by the royal guard Pitou. This
first-ever loss of a loved person affects
Gon deeply, way more than is common for typical
Shounen characters. Much rather Gon has a
very realistic and human response to this
event and develops a rage and thirst for revenge
against Pitou, that is honestly quite unsettling
to watch. As a result, his final act in the
arc is one of the most notorious events in
shonen manga. He uses the heavily injured
and innocent Komugi as mere a tool to blackmail
Pitou, giving no second thought about the
overall situation and threatening to kill
her. Once he learns that Kite is beyond help,
in order to satisfy his wrath against Pitou,
he calls upon all of the potential energy
he will ever have for a short bout of combat
where he brutally kills his opponent without
a single shred of remorse. In doing so, he
trades the rest of his life for one short
moment of violence, as the horrified Killua
is unable to do anything but watch. It’s
some of the most harrowing reading or watching
in the genre, a perverse version of Goku’s
Spirit Bomb. This is Gon’s moment of moral
choice, but instead of having a self-revelation
about what it means to be human and how to
behave justly and morally towards others,
he gives in to his worst instincts. As Killua
abandons his merciless past by forging a relationship
with Gon, his friend sacrifices all of his
remaining humanity for the ultimate act of
revenge — and becoming a monster in the
process. The self-revelation meant for Gon
in this moment of extreme moral and human
complexity, is so obvious that we the readers
have it instead and it makes the scene just
the more dark and uncomfortable to watch.
The reason, why this dark twist on the typical
Shounen protagonist arc works so well with
Gon, is because Togashi has followed one of
the most important rules of writing when creating
his character: Creating empathy - but not
sympathy. Sympathy means that we approve of
the heroes actions and completely identify
with him as a person. If that were to be true
however, we could never have morally challenging
and interesting main characters and every
single story would only serve a very limited
and specific audience, that shares the exact
same views and values as the hero. Empathy
on the other hand means that while we don’t
necessarily approve of the heroes actions,
we do however understand them. We understand
why the hero would make this decision and
how he ultimately reached that moral conclusion.
And as you might suspect, foreshadowing plays
a crucial role in this. It makes the story
cohesive and engaging. So when we apply this
to Gon, while his brutal murder of Pitou and
his failure to keep his humanity are devastating
to watch, we do fully understand why Gon is
behaving this way and thus feel like we are
watching the natural climax to his character
arc. His entire journey has slowly built towards
this dramatic moment and we could unconsciously
witness Gon’s creeping moral decline, without
Togashi having to throw it into our faces.
This is truly great writing. It is a great
endpoint to the story, where Gon ultimately
meets his father and is judged worthy of traveling
with him. He has fulfilled his desire and
going back to the traditional tropes of shounen,
Togashi establishes a new equilibrium. And
as the author stated himself, at this point
in Hunter x Hunter - where Gon meets Ging
- he has pretty much already completed the
story once. Now, you may rightfully say: Doesn’t
hunter x hunter keep going afterwards? And
of course you’re right. However, as you
might know if you follow the manga, Gon is
not currently part of the story and should
he ever appear in it again in the form of
a leading character, he will need a completely
fresh arc with a new desire and now possibly
a positive character arc, where he re-evaluates
his past actions and ultimately regains his
humanity, ending up better and wiser as at
the beginning of the story.
The one who enabled Gon’s second chance
and survival meanwhile was his best friend
Killua, who started off as the coldblooded
and inhuman assassin at the beginning of the
story, who has now completely changed places
with Gon. In many ways Killua is written just
as fantastically as Gon and we will be looking
at his character and role in the story in
the next video of this series. So, stay tuned
for that. Thanks, guys. Peace.